well Denise we're live here outside of
Metro headquarters as the flags here
remain at half staff in honor of Officer
Ty a 23-year veteran of this department
this morning the man accused of killing
him appeared in court as prosecutors say
should he be found guilty he could face
the death penalty
sir I found the probable cause for your
arrest 24 year old Tyson Hampton
appearing in court to hear the charges
against him
is accused of shooting and killing Las
Vegas metro police officer chuang Tai
early Thursday investigators say police
were responding to a call for a domestic
battery involving Hampton they say
Hampton was in a car near the
intersection of Flamingo and University
Center when officers approached and the
shooting occurred in addition to Tai
another person connected to the call for
help was shot and is expected to survive
it's a sad day it didn't have to happen
outside Court Clark County district
attorney Steve Wolfson says if Hampton
had complied with officers the
circumstances would be much different in
other words if he hadn't engaged in the
behavior that caused the tragic loss of
life to officer Tai he may may have only
been arrested for misdemeanor as the
eight news now investigators reported
Thursday Hampton pleaded no contact us
to a gun-related charge two years ago he
was involved in a different family fight
and had threatened a person with a gun
before that police say Hampton had fired
around into a ceiling a judge sentencing
Hampton to community service Wolfson
saying the case was pleaded down due to
others involved in that prior gun charge
not wanting to come to court we can't
proceed if we can't get people to come
to court and cooperate
in that judge ordering Hampton to be
held without bail pending a hearing next
week we also expect Metro to release
more information about this shooting and
what led up to it that is expected to
happen right here next week of course
we'll keep you posted as soon as we
learn more information we are live
outside Metro headquarters tonight I'm
David charns 8 news now Denise